this episode 100 of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know that the cash shop is the
number one app in finance but did you
realize that you can get the most
powerful debit card in the world with
the cash apps cash card just select a
boost in your cash app swipe the cash
card and save 10% or more at Whole Foods
Shake Shack chipotle taco bell
chick-fil-a and all coffee shops around
the country so we'll talk about that
later on in the show and download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play market for the ads for the
ads for the ads for the lads or the ads
on the lads dude I'm Irish so look we
are a little bit Irish so its episode
100 of us congrat of congratulations and
so far for 99 episodes oops I've been
doing it solo and I've been rolling on
my dough low as rappers would say
however episode 100 I thought of doing
something special it's also it's gonna
be Christmas tomorrow so I thought maybe
we'll do something special and we'll get
a guess now I tried to get Jung Claude
Van Damme
he said no obviously because there's no
upside for him to do this up this
podcast so my second option even though
I probably would have wanted Steven
Seagal or anybody so [ __ ] insulting
no not insulting because you don't know
any martial arts but I did bring I did
ask my brother and my brother's name is
Matt Thalia a lot of you guys know him a
lot of you guys you know know I have a
brother this is the one I talk about I
talk about you know a lot of you guys
like when I talk about you know my
family I've noticed which I didn't know
that was gonna be a thing on this
podcast because you know getting
personal is always a little bit weird
especially when you're just sitting down
talking about anything and now there's a
hundred hours of that out there and I'm
sure I said something incriminating and
stuff that my family would hate me for
but definitely my brother is here Matt
Lee
so welcome at the Lea and the one rule
is he just kicked my foot that's not
gonna be happen in this room no that's
yeah I waited for you to sound like you
were finally finishing okay because I've
actually been listening to some of some
of your podcasts all of it no not all of
it definitely all of it because every
time I do listen I think I've [ __ ]
definitely heard that before okay
right I say a lot of the things I say no
you say the same things a lot really but
basically what I realize is I'm gonna be
first guest yeah it's gonna be my
podcast for Magnus isn't knowing what I
was when I was listening I was realizing
I should have been the co-host from the
very yeah you know you you actually
might be right about that
okay well that definitely okay yeah yeah
I might be right about that because I
think the forum but here's the other
thing I think that it's it's too much we
sound the same so I think that you're
gonna have to watch the video podcast of
this to see who the [ __ ] is talking cuz
I think a lot of people say you sound
like me and I sound like you but you
selling me cuz I was first right
timeline-wise no I actually I honestly
don't even think we've sung that much
alike really yeah we do we do we do yeah
you're saying we do yeah you just they
do but we don't sound that much alike we
sound obviously a lite-brite I don't see
how people actually looking mom actually
gets confused yeah mom never mom only go
what do you think the percentage is by
the way of mom calls me you first or she
calls you me first like she goes like
this she'll be like kripp Matthew always
well no it's for me it's a bit chromatic
Bikram for Bill Matt yeah bill bill
Chris Matt they start man you can buy a
Bikram Act for yoga by the way yeah
she's trying to sell me something
vikrum vikrum at 99 for that so wait so
so no she she'll I would say she
probably does it
85% mmm honestly I think she probably I
don't know what is that is there here
when she says Matt mm-hm I'm surprised
yeah yeah
that's a that's how much that doesn't
say Matt it's annoying and just get your
ducks in a row mom do you know what I
mean but so anyway dude this is my
podcast and our podcast right now but
like I don't really have an agenda and I
don't
like have a checklist thing that I go by
because it's not as fun it's more fun to
just kind of wing it most of the time
sometimes I have like bullet points and
[ __ ] but I don't this time because I
figured if I love blaming stuff on other
people as you know yeah yeah yeah so if
this doesn't go well it's your fault all
right yeah that's all good all right
well I already but wait let's talk about
the [ __ ] babies thing because we've
been do we've been talking doing that
forever yeah okay yeah like hello my
baby's walking with today I know so I
did that once or twice on the podcast
and it like took this is one of the
reasons why I wanted you on the on the
thing because we talked about the fact I
talked about the family people seem to
like it a lot but yeah this is that's
one of those things that I let the the
audience kind of decide that it was
going to be a thing yeah I mean yeah
okay well you're a real man of the
[ __ ] you gotta listen to your
audience you gotta listen to your
audience because they will tell you what
they like is you only own 50% of what
you of what you put out there because
the audience owns out a 50% and then
they let you know what it is and you
can't be a dictator okay but the truth
is yeah and that is the truth and you
probably agree with this you would
[ __ ] just do whatever you were gonna
do anyway yeah that's true you were
gonna talk about our family and then you
were like they like when I talk about
the family mmm so you think then you
were like that fits I'm gonna [ __ ]
talk about the family like anyway cuz
you're never not gonna do the thing you
were already gonna do that's true I do
like to talk about the family and if I
wanted to do that I would do that you
would just do it yeah I'm addicted I'm
addicted I'm addicted oh yeah actually
yeah yeah yeah the the family thing now
I think that with our family like when
an outsider comes in mm-hmm they're
usually [ __ ] shocked yeah the first
time they're around all of us yeah
because they they've never been in a
situation where they like they can't get
a word yeah we talk too much I can't say
a word
I guess they even want to I think that
yeah well and yeah well also like my you
know dad and mom talked so much that if
they talked so much and then that we
they created us so now we are beyond
that bright out so they [ __ ] up yeah
and on making us and now we just were
blabber BOTS yeah we won't stop but oh
really annoying yeah it's like time
like a whole family of Vince Vaughn's
but also but also I feel like people cuz
like when we moved out to LA like people
there's a whole thing like on the East
Coast like when you call somebody an
[ __ ] it's not they don't mean I mean
they're a piece of [ __ ] you know what I
mean yeah but in LA when you kill
somebody [ __ ] they get offended yeah
and that's weird to me yeah but I had to
learn that like you're [ __ ] making
somebody feel bad sometimes yeah and
then I also and then on top of that I
had to not give a [ __ ] and still do it
right cuz I'm a bad guy yeah you are a
bad guy I have a good heart but I have a
good heart
no you know what I was thinking about
this is funny I was listening you were
you were saying something you were
saying something about Donald Trump the
other day and I realized that you're
[ __ ] basically Donald Trump hmm
you're saying he's tall no well not the
height he is tall okay but you can't
disagree with that don't disagree with
that got it
so that's one that we're like okay are
you saying I'm tall yeah no but you just
say [ __ ] anything and then are like
that's the best thing yeah okay you
[ __ ] say anything on your [ __ ]
podcast or in real life but especially
on the podcast yeah and you are like
[ __ ] that's the thing that I said
yeah so it's the thing that is right to
say I stand by it yeah yeah okay no yeah
okay yeah that's what you're [ __ ]
Donald Trump then well but I'm but
here's the thing though the difference
between me and Donald Trump is I'm doing
it and it's comedy and he's doing it and
he's president okay it's still really
[ __ ] funny when he does it it is
really funny dude I got to give him that
I actually took that I actually stopped
thinking about how I use [ __ ] phone
is that my phone worst guest of all time
[ __ ] yeah dude that's what you get I saw
you on [ __ ] Brian Collins podcast
[ __ ] texting and [ __ ] the switch I
was texting you by the way okay well now
I feel bad yeah okay so so Donald Trump
so uh yeah I'm I'm I'm yeah it's not
it's it is I took myself I was watching
Donald Trump say something really you
know silly and I was and I laughed and I
thought wow if you don't think about how
[ __ ] up everything is in the country
and
or not you [ __ ] support Donald Trump
you know whatever that even taking that
out yeah anything if if you don't
realize all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] going on
in the world if you don't think about
that and you just look at him he's funny
I would go further what he and say I'm a
dragon would say I would say that even
when you it's maybe especially when
you're thinking if you're in the right
mindset especially when you're thinking
about how [ __ ] up the world it mm-hmm
no that's true how many [ __ ] [ __ ]
things you could be talking about right
right and he's that's true hey it does
make it funnier mocking gun right right
right
so like that is [ __ ] flies by the way
[ __ ] look you can hate Donald Trump
all you want or [ __ ] love him it
doesn't really matter that's [ __ ]
funny yes yeah [ __ ] yeah
to do that I sorry you know yeah well no
not but not sorry though I mean well I
guess sorry yeah yeah I mean even if you
hate him you have to say that is funny
yeah and I hate him you you can do both
yeah it's it's actually very
disconcerting for me when people are
unable to do both of yeah things
yeah it's you're trying to not enjoy
life it's one of those things
yeah well as most people do but it's one
of those things where you think one you
think it's funny
if you don't think about the world being
[ __ ] up but then when you think about
how [ __ ] up the world is it's even
funnier but that's one of those things
where when I say something yeah
okay and I okay I'm in a little bit of
hot water because I said it but if I
stand behind it and say with more
conviction then more people will believe
it
people like to follow my baby okay hang
on [ __ ] Donald Trump you're making a
point mate wrong yeah okay you know from
I know and looking cool I honestly
didn't know Donald Trump was my brother
I'm like no I'm the good I'm the good
I'm no good we're both tall and I'm the
good Donald Trump okay and that's that
and that's what you're saying
obviously all right um so yeah and thank
you you're welcome and I want you to
figure out if you want that zipped up or
not zipped up and then we're gonna don't
want you to figure out why it's this
temperature is a
and room well you have a [ __ ] to let
you have it's going back and forth it's
cold and then no it's not what happens
is you probably have HIV or something
and you're you're just like [ __ ] Tom
Hanks in Philadelphia dude no I'll tell
you something about okay go ahead finish
[ __ ] roasting me and no no no no I'm
not roasting you but you know a little
bit you're dressed like Tom Hanks in
Philadelphia and that's fine you just
don't have the [ __ ] now one fire is
pointing at the fan there's nobody on
and that's why he's one color because
it's already on good produce it's
already a producer that's already on we
have one of those [ __ ] silent dice it
just has a hole in it that's not a
[ __ ] fan that had itself a [ __ ]
thing with a big hole yeah it's like a
yeah oh yeah I feel it
yeah okay so there you go yeah I don't
even know it's not going up or down
oh I put the timer on that's why I can
put it to five there we go it's on five
no no no it doesn't cuz you could just
hear it on the podcast and that's fine
because then you know what I'm talking
about but it's best to show up to the
[ __ ] thing how you're gonna be and
then just that's how you're gonna be
yeah on my podcast which this now is
it's not the rule anymore okay okay
oh one part was saying make it oscillate
is what I meant that's a that's a really
good idea [ __ ] so wanted to say I
didn't know yeah learned I learned the
word officer here yeah so what do I do
hit this [ __ ] thing with the arrows
or what or auto [ __ ] this fan dude what
do you think oscillate is there it's
oscillating
I'm engineer [ __ ] look oh now it's
going to [ __ ] want fire okay there we
go it's that you feel that yeah okay
good so um so what so what so those are
actually really cool socks
thank you yeah you know me I'm mr. sock
guy so yeah I know I like these socks
you know what you're not really into
fashion so much huh no I mean you
definitely have your style which is
awesome you have a good style thank you
and it's it's definitely you yeah and
you do you dress you know what you dress
like somebody that would be in [ __ ]
in an image in the Jughead comics huh
you do the cool guy that gets the girls
yes and it's a bad thing
no I Jughead would be like how come I
can't get the girl from him and that's
how you dress right well I do I wouldn't
say I were the same thing every day but
I do basically yeah I wear I never wear
anything book or open
yeah that's [ __ ] weird okay I'm
finished and I also like I'd like to I
like it when my at least two things are
the same color on my body okay so yeah
that's super [ __ ] uncle vignette it's
terrible it's honestly [ __ ] terrible
yeah I don't like it I don't like I used
to do a lot more [ __ ] like that and I
put all that [ __ ] crazy person energy
only into this you know what's cool is
for sure there's only two of us siblings
here my mom and my dad had two of us hmm
I know I they rang all the OCD out on me
hmm and then there was like the little
quirk left that was left over that's
what you got and you're just like which
is which is better because you know
you're crazy in your own way but now CD
wise no but you're like okay so you're
this how far you go you're like I like
to work to the same colors so you so you
[ __ ] idiot yeah but that's all good
so but so you do so you have your you
put you all so this is something that
it's like I've I feel like you're like
you feel bad about like you feel deeply
bad this is something I admire about you
sorry what sorry about the zipper you
feel deeply bad about her hurting
people's feelings
mmm like deeply I feel like you're like
hyper [ __ ] feel badly about them yeah
I'm very yeah I'm very empathic whether
I like it or not am I like that
absolutely not no no I got all that mm I
got all that so I think it's okay though
CD [ __ ] yeah you know what actually this
is interesting I actually wanted this is
this is the one thing I wanted to talk
about really this yeah cuz it's
Christmas yeah it's a [ __ ] scary
world out there and we're all gonna see
our [ __ ] families mm-hmm that can be
very dreadful it can be scary
mm-hmm and you know if you're like me
very empathic you you're even feeling
bad even if you feel good and then
somebody comes up and they're in a bad
mood you're like oh now
yeah and then you feel bad because
someone else felt bad that's not a good
way to live your life right so I have a
lot of experience with feeling really
bad right okay so so I have a lot of
experience feeling really bad hmm
I figured out how to never feel bad oh
do you no no but I think you're wrong
already
no I think you might even agree to be
honest okay this is like some real [ __ ]
this is real this is it's real okay so
one thing you can tell about something
that's gonna be realized if somebody
says this is real no but I preface it
like that because I [ __ ] know okay
when the right when I say it people are
gonna think I'm not serious okay like
imagine the [ __ ] mean that's my whole
life the first [ __ ] guy that was like
yeah rub two woods together and it's
fire well you could just demonstrate
right I know but you say that the guys
like no you can then the guy doesn't you
know I mean they're not talking cuz
you're like man but your church or today
okay so but it's like the first guy that
was like when you come in a girl that
makes a baby well no you could just
demonstrate that okay so I was like this
guy died you know the geez like the
Christian you like and you're [ __ ]
crazy guy right so but then some people
now look around the world hey man look
around the world right a lot of churches
right yeah somebody believed it right
and so it must have [ __ ] worked for
somebody
yeah okay I'm not religious it's not why
but we should start a church I do well
yeah and it this could be its foul guess
you know [ __ ] tenet okay this is
[ __ ] real [ __ ]
okay this is for any time you're gonna
feel you might feel bad someone makes
you feel bad all throughout every day
it's bad [ __ ] you look at the news bat
[ __ ] you think about your feelings bad
[ __ ]
you think about what people think you
bad [ __ ] only bad [ __ ] always only all
the time bad [ __ ] right mm-hm sometimes
it's like okay yeah rarely is it [ __ ]
great I can make it well if you're
coming right
you know that's rare though it's like 3
X 7 seconds of coming versus 23 hours
and 59 minutes of non [ __ ] 47 seconds
that's a good amount
and I was even right actually we got
around okay and anyway so okay it's
actually you so in any situation like
this it's sort of like all-purpose right
you the student is an example first say
I'm wondering if it's taking you too
goddamn long to say I know it is
that's part of how do you make how you
make sure people know you're [ __ ]
sure that's true that's true I guess
that's a good point you ever listen to
anybody and be a serious talk
yeah this is how your name PR it was the
33 minutes before the make a point so
true right is it true that monkey is you
know the mean in your leg off
yeah yeah yeah you can take a break in
the middle and just [ __ ] pick back up
at the end but you can't do that now cuz
all of it matters
okay so say something that I won't like
okay hold on you have to say I have to
actually have to know I'm not gonna like
it so hold on before you do it because
you know me very well you can say
something about me that you know I won't
like it has to be something you know I
won't like in in real life or just may
not to say something it doesn't have to
be about yeah I got you remind me of
something I don't like okay [ __ ]
whatever so hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna
you're gonna say it yeah I'm gonna say
the way you respond and then no matter
what it is you don't feel bad anymore
you're gonna say okay okay okay yeah
doesn't it suck that everyone you know
is gonna be dead it can't be a question
oh okay hey everyone you know is gonna
be dead one day okay so yes No okay that
was a terrible thing to say yeah every
every [ __ ] person I've ever known
yeah is gonna die yeah okay you just say
kka why yeah yeah okay like okay no it's
not I mean yeah no but that's the word
you're you're you're not just saying
okay I'm like poaching fear that yeah
yeah yeah okay okay yeah but here's the
thing you could say it a different way
to write say something like alright okay
so I got one so uh yeah the [ __ ] it
sucks my my house was in the Malibu
fires and it burned down
okay yeah that's I mean I would I love
that see oh okay so I love that
two for two no here's the thing of for
real though you could do it about
anything your [ __ ] Christmas and
writing your mom is like needling you
how come you don't yeah you don't have a
girl and I think that it's gay you're
getting it's getting you're getting too
old and you're not gonna be able to be a
good dad you're gonna be too old to be a
dad okay fair enough right like you
could say it right you could say other
words with Kay okay but then the mom
might be like what do you mean no you
know it's not for her yeah they say the
shitty mom
so you feel better when you do it's for
yeah yes bring I cares about other
people I get it who would you do that's
the whole [ __ ] point okay not is okay
right okay so that's the thing right I
used to [ __ ] brood all day yeah this
is serious talk to anybody on no [ __ ]
one fire knows anybody my [ __ ] life
that knows me well enough is in my life
for the last eight months knows what
happened yeah and that's what happened
okay yeah I I love really like that yeah
it'll work honestly everyone's gonna be
like either haha you know what does he
talk about just honestly just please try
it please try it you're gonna be with
your family anyway watch your [ __ ]
twitch now about it yes I probably do
some videos and I will I will say it's
probably has something it's probably
like the d'haran Brown thing yeah well
it could be you're interrupting
something that's very like a handshake
just okay and they're like what and they
policy it also does it to your own brain
though you can surprise yourself if you
do it enough you you bury it in the
[ __ ] cerebellum part of the brain of
a scientist I'm a scientist I know okay
so you bury it in the cerebellum so it's
just yeah okay okay so it's sort of like
it's freeing it's it is it definitely is
friend it's gonna put meditation out of
business okay yeah Wow cuz you don't
need it anymore i I agree is the same
thing agree it does do the same thing it
might not do it as well but maybe if you
get maybe if you get a sort of like on a
roll with it again it could be the kind
of a thing like the Church of Kay right
yeah exactly I just think people need to
do it and learn it's not like you can
really explain it I showed you all but
it's not the same until you'd really do
it mm-hmm III think that we should do
that
I'm gonna start doing that yeah yeah you
know I know you've been saying Kay a lot
and text changes and stuff like that
it's yeah I'm really I'm evangelizing
that's cool that's very cool that's it's
very [ __ ] to do it that way yeah by the
way yeah but sometimes if somebody was
like how my mom just died okay yeah
that's so rude well but it's free but it
is for you yeah but also if you're gonna
get into a like somebody's [ __ ] with
you yeah but you would have [ __ ] hey
yeah not gonna happen right right okay
that is true way you know what Darren
brown was saying that one time he was
going to get in a fight and the guy said
the guy was like you want to [ __ ]
fight and he said something like yeah I
think the wall around my house is about
four feet tall but it might be my not
yeah I said I'm stay there yeah yeah
yeah I'm that a very similar dumb brain
yeah well you yeah okay sure everything
about this cake yeah how do you feel oh
yeah I feel good because you know maybe
I didn't agree with you even I just said
Kay it was freeing it was a freeing
thing yeah it's for you man Wow it
doesn't matter if I even hear it Wow
dude and and but so then how do you feel
about how we look oh nice [ __ ] segue
but because I want at the monitor and I
think I look [ __ ] like pretty like
good in this in and I think that you
maybe look like a like the hair like
like me but I did heroin for a long time
yeah I think I think I agree with that
well you look healthy it looks like you
do heroin but also eat fruit okay there
you go
Wow feel good yeah it also would make me
mad if somebody kept doing it maybe you
have to do it sparingly or no or it's
just for you you do it quiet it makes me
less a little less mad if the microphone
wasn't here you wouldn't even [ __ ] I
know it'd be for you so you could go
under your breath but so so we both
agree what like I'm like I look like you
if I if we put them if you put the mask
on if Jim Carrey you put the mask on
like if I get smoked in they go like oh
that's Matt D'Elia with the mask on look
if I put on a yellow suit and end end
also your [ __ ] socks they'd be like
whoa
Matt's [ __ ] you know I'm saying
what's the [ __ ] what's that song from
the [ __ ] mask Cuban Pete oh wow yes
so fast with it yeah they call me Cuban
Pete I'm the king of the Rumba be in
veneto Jake ticky boom Chicka Chicka
Boom Chicka Chicka Boom dude let me tell
you something dude that [ __ ] how
goddamn funny is Jim Carrey
he's definitely extremely underrated
well he's so hot but that's not enough
okay he puts me on the floor he's so
[ __ ] funny that it's [ __ ] yeah he
is because there's layers right like
there's this subtle funny that's very
hard to do because you have to be subtle
enough and not go overboard if you're
totally doing some
subtle yeah right then there's the silly
kind of [ __ ] that like I don't know if
you're a fan of like you know certain
people like Will Ferrell or Ryan
Reynolds or whoever they do silly movies
and they do this stuff they fall on the
floor or whatever yeah that's hard as
well yes but then there's the Jim Carrey
[ __ ] which is so if he did it a hair off
it would just be obnoxious dunno I'm
talking about but he does it he does it
all wholeheartedly
he puts all of himself into it but also
he has the talent and the way he's on
that wavelength it's just it is brave I
hate when people say this [ __ ] but it's
just it's just the ultimate maximum
level of funny and if anybody [ __ ]
disagrees with me I go like this okay
yeah yeah because now we're talking I
mean he's them for me I mean obviously
he already is although oh yeah a funny
person yeah he's the most committed
human being yeah a human being that is
true even with everything yeah yeah I
mean you seem on a talk show he's like
[ __ ] I know standing on the chair I
know two seconds I love that and I
remember when we were younger mom used
to be like cuz I used to love Jim Carrey
or I mean I do love to have a people my
mom would be like she knew I was such a
big fan of Jim Carrey and then we would
see like him on late-night TV but
because we would watch like the [ __ ]
interviews and [ __ ] or whatever the [ __ ]
that we would see somebody else on
late-night that was like the cool guy
funny like more like charismatic funny
like like I don't I don't know I'm
charismatic you don't mind me no I
wasn't you because you were [ __ ] six
and you weren't on Letterman without a
bit but I heard so let me hear you
something did you poop your pants so
what's going around in their life I did
poopy so so so she would say see you
know Chris you don't always have to do
all that crazy stuff you can just be me
it's much funnier to just be like that
yeah about non Jim Carrey yeah I mean
she liked Jim Carrey but like but it was
weird - is that mom's favorite [ __ ]
comedian you know who it is right oh
actually I do yeah
Sinbad yes yeah she loves Sinbad
and Sinbad is also one of the [ __ ] he is
so funny
he's [ __ ] really funny yeah so uh so
oh by the way I saw Sinbad on a flight
one said he goes like that he's like
what's up Chris and I was like oh what's
up I was just happy that he even knew
who I was and he had a [ __ ] leopard
print kerchief with him
where was it on the plane now where was
the kerchief
where was he carrying it was all on the
plane but like yeah I'm kidding he had
it on his knee just wait just like he's
doing a [ __ ] magic trick yeah hey
Chris what's going on you want to be as
I am [ __ ] were there already
dude he it was so amazing that he had
that oh dude
and that's the story Sinbad that's it
the pirate or him yeah okay worse that
right there was the worst five seconds
about any podcaster I ever seen in my
life Sinbad yeah sorry I just saw words
and I got distracted no reading no it's
okay a barracuda a [ __ ] barracuda
okay let's do some ads here and you're
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] through it like a
[ __ ] good brother okay okay there you
go wow that one so it's so obnoxious
actually okay look I got to [ __ ] ads
because it's Christmas and you're gonna
sit through them and you're a baby and
you're not anyway if your baby and you
listen to it you're not gonna [ __ ]
rewind you're not gonna fast-forward
through it okay I know that sometimes
you hit the fast-forward button you're
not gonna do that
it's Christmas I'm doing two of them so
you're gonna listen to them and that's
it SeatGeek
getting tickets online can be far too
complicated you know that with hundreds
of sites and varying levels of real
reliability it's hard to know who to
trust
that's why SeatGeek is the way to go
SeatGeek pulls millions of tickets into
one place so you can easily find the
seats you want for a price you're
willing to pay there's nothing quite
like being there in person and SeatGeek
will get you closer to the action for a
great value SeatGeek is designed to make
your ticket buying experience easier
than ever by searching multiple ticket
sites and grading every ticket based on
value SeatGeek helps you immediately
identify the best seats that fit your
budget Matt did it for the band puddle
of mud and it really worked out plus
every purchase is fully guaranteed that
happened with Matt when he went to go
see stained so you can shop for tickets
on SeatGeek
with confidence
and makes you geek your go-to ticket
source for everything from sports
concert to come in theater or for if
you're mad you want to go see who it's
Hoobastank using SeatGeek
I have this app on my phone it comes in
handy best of all my listeners get $10
off their first SeatGeek purchase just
download the CQ gap and enter promo code
Congrats today
that's promo code congrats for $10 off
your first seat gig purchase SeatGeek
life's an event we have tickets cash up
you already know the cash app is the
number one app in finance but did you
realize that you can get the most
powerful debit card in the world with
cash apps cash card the cash card comes
with boosts a feature you can't get
anywhere else because cash app invented
it just select a boost in your cash app
swipe the cash card and save 10% or more
at Whole Foods shake check Chipotle Taco
Bell chick-fil-a and all coffee shops
around the country the coffee shop boost
takes $1 off at any coffee shop
including Dunkin and Starbucks drink a
hundred cups per year save $100 is that
simp become a part of the greatest
rewards program ever and download the
cash app now it's the number one app for
reason and cash card is the only debit
card with boosts and of course when you
download the cash app and enter the
referral code congrats you'll receive $5
and the cash app will send $5 to the
times up Legal Defense Fund visit the
App Store or Google Play market and
download the cash app I love the cash
app I use it to pay back everybody I pay
back my friends my foes I pay back
acquaintances and I also pay I pay back
one time I pay back a lizard that had to
catch up that's how easy it is and Matt
paid me back for the puddle of mud
tickets when we used it to get on the
cat on the on the couch op so anyway ok
ok hey man what
now
I like this song turn it lower for sure
okay you just have that's violent is
very violent it's very violent and
forgot about it so I had to [ __ ] make
use of it
yeah why you forgot about it because the
[ __ ] the conversation we have is so
riveting right so in - yeah you know -
so rhythm but still speaking of that's
awesome
you want more loads that Scarface I like
that yeah it was Scarface okay we talked
about how you are as a host yeah okay
[ __ ] bad
no yeah because I'm so now I texted you
have with this okay yeah yeah no that's
that's exactly good right then why am i
bad host I texted you a couple days ago
okay how do you want to do this
yeah no response yeah there's never been
a guest do you have any ideas not what
you want to do I texted you that and you
responded I'll think nothing I said I
said let me know I'm down for whatever
you said okay write two letters and
we're good
and we're good hey one fire it's fine
dude how [ __ ] is he now that he has
the [ __ ] controls he's like you know
[ __ ] with it and [ __ ] dude I here's
the thing man when you find out what you
want to do in your life you just do it
you do it you don't do any extra [ __ ]
people do all this extra [ __ ] [ __ ] do
it I'm just smooth sailing I'm down for
a silly goose time and that's it what I
don't want to do is print some [ __ ] out
that's what I don't want to do yeah yeah
yeah
so what other [ __ ] did they do though
what besides print [ __ ] out you're
saying like what extra [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
well print [ __ ] out to the main one all
right like an environmental thing or you
just no no no like you're just like like
like when they any time anybody makes a
list with one of those [ __ ] dots on
it and then what to do and then another
dot and then what to do yeah get the
[ __ ] out of town do it got far out of
town put a vest with a bunch of pockets
on
you know the rest okay I mean everything
just fits but I bent it put a vest with
a bunch of pockets on it and you know
the rest there we go okay I thought it
was gonna stop but it didn't it made
you're gonna get in a man and I'm mad
it's all good with big cotton balls
stuffed in your nose well it sounds so
[ __ ] nasal I was sick when I did that
one yeah and there we go he knows his
brother and he knows his brother babies
and it's fine malfunctioning so what do
you think of hip-hop oh well I used to
love all I know now I don't love hip-hop
how come I don't know what's happening
yeah ever I know what is happening well
I don't know how about that dude well I
don't get it well it's fine and some of
its good but I feel myself like having
to [ __ ] like it having to pretend to
like it because it's what's in like you
know what I was I was watching I was
watching that Eminem and it was like he
just does the thing that he does and
he's been doing it for so long and
hip-hop has definitely changed but it's
like what it's changed into his not
something I like but that's what happens
with every [ __ ] generation yes now
that I'm 38 and you're [ __ ] you're 21
22 yeah I just turned 22 um yeah it just
[ __ ] he's not out there just so
because if somebody don't realize that
we're joking but yeah no I'm not 22 yeah
what what I just feel old like but that
doesn't just happen with hip-hop though
[ __ ] all happens with everything oh
cool no but really I feel like that
would you know so many things I feel 30
years older than really cuz shit's just
it's going everything's going way too
fast right now yeah well people probably
getting older quicker because of that
there now because of the exponential
[ __ ] with the technology and all that
nice you know what I mean yeah but I'm
[ __ ] smart you know I say stuff like
that and I shut it down no I don't know
if you're smart well honestly when
people ask me about what I'm like in
regards to you I say I'm like you but
smart no do you say you [ __ ] or the
string bean version of me no the only
word that would be true by though and it
would be okay if I said it but also it
says weird you don't wear jeans bro
don't like jeans you why don't like to
have them [ __ ] touching my legs okay
so
that's the kind of [ __ ] that I do so
that's Donald Trump no its but I'm not
standing here saying don't worry no one
should wear jeans that's what you should
ease our four rapists well I don't know
that but no you don't they but like but
I will say something
blankets say something I bet more people
more more people have performed rapes
while wearing jeans than than any other
kinds of pants
maybe shorts though that seems like a
rapist there's definitely cargo shorts
number one rape for sure no you know
what most rapists in history wearing yes
I do
oakley sunglasses absolutely nothing
because most rapists were around way
before clothes oh okay well I'm talking
about the current situation of it gotcha
technicality oh please Sangha and I
think I won that one oakley sunglasses
yeah well that yeah but yeah I don't
like how you had to take it all [ __ ]
smart in in it to a new historic level
I'm a scientist and an anthropologist
and a lot of [ __ ] like that other [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] went downhill so
quickly no I'm I'm a scientist I'm an
anthropologist and a lot of [ __ ] like
that
oh not [ __ ] respect well I'm a
geneticist that I [ __ ] know I am oh
but not you don't know you're the other
ones know that I'm positive up but you
know you're a geneticist no no I'm a
geneticist everyday okay and you're an
anthropologist how often a week like
five five or six days and you're a
scientist
seven days a week yeah yeah so you're a
scientist as much as you're a geneticist
yeah those are the two big ones and by
the way what we're doing right now is
the worst version of what happened on
Costello ever did it's also what we do
all the [ __ ] I know I'm always I mean
I'll just [ __ ] text you I'm Tim I'm
[ __ ] you never I'm [ __ ] buffer
than I used to be though and you never
really [ __ ] address that you never
[ __ ] say anything about that you
never say like Chris your looking big
and beefy but and that's [ __ ]
honestly very weird yeah I don't say
that how come I don't think about
bigness and beefiness bogan when I'm
faced with it okay well so you're not
observant then I observe it I'm just
thinking about [ __ ] I'd rather be thing
so how quickly if I'm beefy if I'm
beefier than I've been to when I walk
into effets though because that's what
it is it's beef Dinty Moore the
I do can ramen things no no no
so I'm beefy a little bit bigger than I
have been and that's the [ __ ]
Rollerson just say that but it's the
elephant in the room okay now when I
when you see me after a few weeks and
when I've been on the road and I come
back and I'm a little bit beefier how
quickly does that go through your brain
if you're observant how quickly does it
go through brain like a [ __ ] breeze
through a screen door okay goes right
through because I don't give a [ __ ] okay
but you do register it know so you know
you're not observant then it's either or
I got you [ __ ] pissed now dude all
right all right okay you know wait hold
on do I mean [ __ ] submission do it if
it's not on [ __ ] call you know
because it's too far it's too far we
have a little table I know we have a
little two [ __ ]
dude always talking about
beefiness dude yeah but you'd be like if
you talked about a longer you'd be like
in it's beefy sucking a dick no [ __ ]
gymnast I know thank you I'm a gymnast
seven days a week but gymnast as much as
you are a scientist so together we could
do a lot of [ __ ] for for the world yeah
yeah yeah so what what do you what do
you want to [ __ ] talk about I know
you did the K thing and I agree and I
get it oh I know what I want to talk
about okay oh dude
oh no don't [ __ ] talk about okay I'm
gonna [ __ ] rock you know I made a
joke earlier about how this is my
podcast no it's not okay well that was
quick it was for heavy [ __ ] nine
almost 40 minutes okay
I [ __ ] I'm gonna have my own [ __ ]
podcast okay
and one I don't like how you gave him a
sound board by the way
oh I insisted it okay I insisted then I
like that a little better and I
definitely knew you wouldn't like it and
that problem a cue like it even more it
makes me like I like how much I don't
like it I gotta be honest because I like
when somebody is committed about their
[ __ ] and it's committed and it's I like
it it's interesting it's interesting
it's interesting so Cocteau say it's
interesting it's interesting because it
that is kind of like kind of like the
idea of the [ __ ] podcast and I want
to [ __ ] give too much away it's gonna
be the best podcast
okay well better than your podcast okay
okay is it a comedy podcast or a regular
podcast if I feel [ __ ] funny it'll be
[ __ ] hilarious
alright okay I will probably be feeling
funny on any given day so god damn
foreign I will probably be feeling funny
and a given on any given goddamn day
all right you talked you actually
learning English fine now that I finally
listened to your [ __ ] podcast I heard
you talk a little bit about how people
don't [ __ ] talk to each other enough
and that's probably because that's one
thing we always [ __ ] talk about okay
people shouting each other down and then
they get on the [ __ ] fringes and then
yeah and talk to each other and they're
in their coach chamber what they're
[ __ ] saying yeah that sucks right and
I feel like people don't know how to
argue anymore because arguing is [ __ ]
really fun and I don't see people having
fun doing that yeah true you know I mean
and so argue to me arguing is the most
fun thing either lose an argument really
badly yeah then not being one okay I
mean sure and I just feel like the
conversations that I am hearing people
aren't [ __ ] talking to each other and
I want to be able to [ __ ] have
anybody anybody who's been sort of maybe
sidelined or doesn't have a [ __ ]
voice to talk about the main [ __ ] right
mm-hmm
the way you put it was [ __ ] way
better than me why don't you pitch my
[ __ ] podcast for me dude like Brett
Favre yeah pitch it well he's not a
pitcher he's a football player well I
don't know but you said no but no but
Brett Favre is what happened that what
happened to him
oh it would be a podcast oh yeah he
would be
yeah so you so it's okay to talk about
what it is yeah I guess okay all right
so it's a podcast where you I put it
well you think now I'm gonna talk about
okay so that's what parka is good for
you can [ __ ] it up and I be like wait
that's true at another point you're
gonna interview people that have fallen
from grace that have had crazy wild
things happen to them that are now are
being shamed like Anthony Weiner or I
mean you talk about shame on here yeah
right I do yeah yeah but so you want to
interview those people because a lot of
those people they don't get the the the
the the the the media won't interview
those people because they don't want to
give them a platform yeah which I think
that's doing a disservice to
conversation in the world because you're
not getting everybody talking with each
other yeah and these fringe people don't
get to talk about their ideas and get
them [ __ ] put in their place because
the only interviews that they're doing
are people not in the media that don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
and so they'll take an interview and a
guy like who the was ago to cowboy hat
the white guy would think yeah okay you
were talking about oh no I'm sorry I'm
thinking about am i thinking about the
[ __ ] adult right guy he doesn't work
have a hat but Richard Spencer Jesse yes
yes yes Richard Spencer professor should
wear [ __ ] : yeah he should that's why
I thought he was working yeah so he he
he I mean CNN won't interview him so so
the people who do interview him are not
the leading people and then he'll walk
all over those people because his
arguments are [ __ ] well thought out
whether or not you agree with them with
yeah yeah yeah obviously I mean in
general I just want ideas that people
sort of kick to the side to get out in
the [ __ ] open and to be able to talk
about anything and [ __ ] everything
and also dude everybody's so [ __ ]
serious about [ __ ] I know and I don't
think that's good no it should be there
should be a lot of K going on it's not
it's not [ __ ] well dude here's the
thing anybody who comes on that I
disagree with if they [ __ ] rock my
[ __ ] ass okay but yeah
[ __ ] you in the butt you mean okay right
there you go that is the only attitude
to have about a [ __ ] argument you you
have to [ __ ] go in and be ready to
[ __ ] lose right right because
otherwise you're not listening right and
people my people aren't [ __ ]
listening they're just [ __ ] yelling
but now people are just yelling to each
other about [ __ ] they already [ __ ]
agree about yeah and I don't want to do
that even if I already [ __ ] agree
with you right right right that isn't
interesting to me well like a lot of
times I agree with CNN but also a lot of
times you can smell their agenda and
it's annoying as [ __ ] you can smell
everybody's right where I write no no
yeah and the best thing about a
scientist and anthropologist and
geneticists are the white lab coats like
myself is they don't have an agenda
right and well I don't have any rep that
can be [ __ ] broken by having some guy
that's good that's why you build your
rep like that like that's what I would
always say about you [ __ ] went on
like Twitter and stuff like I would
tweet the crazy [ __ ] and get the fan
base that way right because if you're
[ __ ] like people expect that [ __ ]
from Kanye West right but if somebody
like whoever yeah you know that like
Chris Evans right right he was just like
duh [ __ ] up with all this yellow [ __ ]
going on you know right right even if
you tweeted something like hey there's a
lot of Asians at Kmart today people will
be like oh he's not Captain America
anymore right right but that's nothing
but if I did it people be like our crews
just being a [ __ ] wacko that's what
he does that's why we follow him right
yeah yeah I mean for me what I
definitely know is if a thing like that
existed I'd be the thing I'd want to
listen to you know how much Mewis and
Lou talk but that's well but that's what
you got to do you got to do the thing
that you want to [ __ ] see in the
world right not try [ __ ] yeah I mean
I wanna [ __ ] get into [ __ ] it's okay
I'm on fire it's right there I see you
good time um he clicked to stop watching
cleared to stop watch and now we don't
know how long it's going but I look over
on the monitor and it's okay and I
haven't get rid of came through with the
video but one fire [ __ ] it all up with
the other [ __ ] so it's all good nice no
it no it he writes one fire writes no it
quit okay well no it didn't dude you
[ __ ] it up for sure
I mean the way he typed that was like oh
slow and so you're a three-year-old and
bonobo and he also has more [ __ ] to say
about everybody's things you know what
I'm just gonna let it be immature
[Laughter]
dude so yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] rock
that's good that'll be a good no but
there's there's no rock in my ass no
rock your ass cause I'm gonna get more
[ __ ] people - oh okay well I want
that yeah also and when you [ __ ] do
something finally that even [ __ ]
everything up like you goat me oh yeah
finally yeah like you know I can be on
your podcast
exactly yeah okay well it's probably
soon so wait I got some [ __ ] to say
about it okay okay yeah you can go to
Matt D'Elia com2 join our newsletter
which I'll only use for important
announcement and great porn links that's
ma TT de li acecomm you'll know how to
spoil your goddamn name but yeah just
kidding about the porn links yeah will
that people unsubscribe people put up
subscribe and then unsubscribe when you
said that yeah well that's cool yeah
it's like it's like when you put
something on your list on Netflix and
then [ __ ] when it drops it says hey
it's available yeah I didn't know that
was a thing until really yeah did one
fire [ __ ] told me that [ __ ] when
today yesterday about Netflix yeah or
yours not the thing that I can do that I
can do it oh god yeah okay you can do it
yeah well that I know you can do it
actually from my thing that's coming out
on January 1st comedians of the world
that drops so yeah I have a new special
coming out is it [ __ ] where's that
big-ass billboard for that I guess it's
coming up soon I don't know huh it'll be
it'll be here though and you'll be able
to see my face driving down kawaii or
something probably yeah are you sweating
no no right now me neither
oh good dude how about when people ask
something yeah and they obviously are
that yeah because they want to know if
someone else is oh yeah like what I just
did right right right right but I'm in
it but they're [ __ ] serious yeah it's
amazing it's amazing on a bunch of
different levels and I'll take you're
saying like you're saying like like like
do an example I have a [ __ ] great one
actually okay we we were talking about
we were talking about [ __ ] gross
[Music]
genitalia I'm making it up didn't tell
you
no I'm just trying to think about how I
should [ __ ] say this cuz this is
pretty [ __ ] I gotcha it's okay I he's
good right if ever listen to my podcast
you say
like genuinely terrible [ __ ] right well
yeah crass yeah I mean but also just do
it in an in an actual way and you're
good don't be like a so [ __ ] don't
okay so yeah we're talking about [ __ ]
beef curtains on vagina okay alright
I've said I've said baboon rudders so
yeah yeah and then so we're talking
about beef curtains
okay well it's okay we're talking about
beef curtains this is what we were
talking about and somebody who was there
that wasn't directly linked to the
conversation mhm
just said I don't have beef curtains
right you know instantly they have beef
curtains you have beef curtains right
right that's it that's a good example
yeah so you know instantly because they
chimed in why would you say you don't be
right exactly
it's like when a girl comes over to your
apartment and you're like and they're
like by the way we're not having sex and
you're like I didn't mention [ __ ] yeah
and then yeah and you know you're gonna
do the [ __ ] horizontal mambo
eventually and you know you're gonna do
the oh and it's going to happen and it's
fun yeah it's gonna go Murray till the
break of dawn they've got it going on
right yeah I know that yeah so I wonder
if they know that I won't but they have
to know it deep down but they don't know
it on the level dude I don't know I
don't know if yeah I guess I don't know
that in you're the scientist seven days
a week but but I think that it's amazing
on so many levels because first of all
the less you say the less incriminated
you're going to be about yourself so you
go you throw that right out right away
yeah yeah yeah right yeah also you are
tricking yourself and you're lying to
everybody but you're also lying to
yourself it's just a whole [ __ ] mess
yeah it's like this is what I find I
guess guys do this a lot too but I find
girls do this in in my circle the most
girls will be like I never go out
yeah right right right right and you're
saying that because you want people to
think you don't go out but you go out
all the time you know and that's why all
of your Instagram pictures and stories
are you drinking champagne so it's weird
it's like saying hi I'm not wearing any
clothes and you're wearing
[ __ ] a shirt and pants right because
that's the same exact thing here's my
thing though and those are the worst
kinds of people in the world yeah but
why do they want to seem like they'd I
don't know that's the other thing it's
not even a bad thing go out and who
cares dude what's why do people give a
[ __ ] about the way they are they didn't
[ __ ] pick it yeah I know I know well
but they don't want to be a loser
quote/unquote I guess but then it's not
losers because people will be like oh
I'm such a grandma like will give self a
[ __ ] oh you stayed home what do you want
to [ __ ] I don't give it what do you
want some [ __ ] I don't get it I
actually don't even [ __ ] yeah I don't
get I don't get it either but yeah but
it is very very prevalent and those
kinds of people are the worst kinds of
people in the world okay well I mean
that's so [ __ ] extreme though yeah I
know but they're yeah they're they're
just as bad as racists okay you know
what maybe this [ __ ] made me think of
I was [ __ ] reading a book read a lot
books okay read a lot of [ __ ] books
me too there's a [ __ ] I was reading
about this study about men who identify
as homophobic all right it was a study
and they admit it and they know they are
or they they associated like other
qualities that generally align with
homophobia okay okay and so they put
them in this rig like they put this
thing around their dick and they get
really detailed but I think it's like
how did you get this [ __ ] thing on
their dick right okay but it's like
basically a lie detector but for your
[ __ ] dick whoa right so they put all
this other [ __ ] I think I read it in
strangers to ourselves is the name of
this book by this guy Timothy Wilson's
[ __ ] Austen book
strangers what strangers to ourselves
yeah Timothy I think it's Timothy Wilson
probably ready awesome book you
definitely read it and you put and and
and these guys who identify as
homophobic or just at least strongly
heterosexual they're like yeah they
start 2% they start to perspire when
they see the gay porn right and they
start to get a little bit of a [ __ ]
chubby penis Wow yeah and that's the
technical term I'm a doctor so a penis
so so so so basically they hate it
because they want to do it well yeah so
do you think that it's
part of it is they're gay
or do you think part of it is they the
excitement and the tab unas of it is
what turns them on because they know
that both yeah both yeah but I think
that that is only more [ __ ] reason to
let everybody know it's okay to [ __ ]
blast guys oh yeah you know I mean yeah
it's a way okay like if everybody knew
was okay to [ __ ] blast guys yeah for
guys whenever they want to blast guys no
one would be they would even be able you
wouldn't be able do the [ __ ] study in
the first place right yeah yeah we blast
guys it'd be like I don't put this on
the on your penis to see if you like if
you'd like to blast guys and be like I
liked about guys it's over yeah and then
they just that's it right yeah
the study would be would be done yeah um
you know the only thing that ever you
know how like you knew talking about
echo-chamber yeah and you talk about
like how like you know how it's so hard
to change somebody's mind just because
they're just it's pretty much actually
impossible yeah right and so I was
online and the only thing that had like
I like you know I try to be open-minded
obviously everyone should try and be
open-minded but in a lot of cases I'm
not and the only thing that ever [ __ ]
totally changed my mind a stranger
online changed my mind and it was when I
used to have this joke about how it was
my first special be prior remember but
it was like if if if you hate gay people
I remember yeah I remember right cuz
nobody has nobody feels that strongly
about something unless you're trying to
hide something about it right and I was
like I was like like say like if you
hate a butterface like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
butterfingers I hate butterfingers so
much be like it what happened between
you and a Butterfinger right that was
the joke and so I thought that everybody
who hated gay people was secretly gay
actually thought that yeah and then I
read a tweet from somebody that was like
you that's not true and also if you do
that it's secretly blaming gay people
for homophobia do you understand it took
me I to read
like seven times yeah yeah and I was
like and I was like that's so true
that's very true but but I don't know if
I I don't know if now I'm totally all
the other way like I but I think now
that you can like have hatred for people
who have sex with the same sex without
ink without being gay yeah well
absolutely for sure
yeah but I that feels more like a tribal
thing where it's like I do this this is
natural you know I mean but the whole
reproduction thing I think they come
more from that side of it
who's they people that have a problem
with oh right yeah it's less about like
oh yeah definitely it's more like that's
not the way it's done true yeah that's
true I mean this is not the way we do it
you know they're like that right we're
like this is basically the source of
every [ __ ] right right right there's
some version of that you're a bit like
that with jeans huh you should start
wearing jeans honestly yeah it's gonna
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna start a [ __ ]
war on jeans because you are like only
of corduroys only corduroys and you're
basically homophobic is what I'm saying
I about jeans I'm running for [ __ ]
president and my platform one of my
platforms is a war on jeans nice I would
by the way vote for that and I love
jeans yeah just because I need somebody
to shake things up right I'd be [ __ ]
I'd be a [ __ ] awesome president to be
honest all right that's okay
y know about my [ __ ] platforms okay
[ __ ] I I understand thought about it
that much uh well that's not good but
I'll tell you what Donald Trump didn't
think about that much at your age no I
think I think are you gonna start now I
just had this idea dude okay well you're
35 yeah I just start I just [ __ ] out
this idea okay when now right now I'm
gonna be here at the podcast right here
okay [ __ ] president dude okay guys
this is crazy is on camera oh wow I'm
gonna [ __ ] be president guys it's okay
well not not not not obviously in four
year or two years whatever it is but get
back to you about my platforms when I
develop them no in 2020 yeah have them
subscribe to it already so they get
notification about like the later
podcast they're gonna learn about my
foreign policy and all that [ __ ] nice
yeah well I don't know
do you want to do should we do like
craigslist ads with Matt that might be
fun have you heard me do that yet uh
yeah yeah yeah oh wow cool all right do
you want to do misconnections should we
do it now
what's that yeah well we can do it or
whatever you got it you want to piss or
now I'm good okay all right let's do it
let's [ __ ] look him up you got
someone on static guy friends is the
title my longtime guy friend has moved
away we had great times so far it's
really sad I mean this is this is like
[ __ ] flow Barre what's up with this
[ __ ] I service it's what it's like what
it's like flow Barre it's like that
what's flow mayor I'm a [ __ ] author
some French author is that what that is
yeah I know it's a French author on flow
mer what is it what it flow Barre blow
me down flow Barre flow Barre what are
you [ __ ] saying flow Barre who stop
[ __ ] filming Flaubert dude it's
[ __ ] flower vase so good stop sorbet
what am i [ __ ] doing here I don't
know dude you picked up chords all right
so my long [ __ ] it yeah guy friends
my longtime guy friend has moved away I
had great times I serviced him when he
wanted Wow
I'm looking for a new friend to hang out
with for good clean fun from time to
time I'm a man by the way
ha ha I want to be the bottom do not
contact me with unsolicited services or
offers I just think it's crazy how being
too vague you know what's funny is until
the very end he's got to really like
good details but there was like don't
you talking about I'm the by the way is
the main thing that you have to start
with true by the way
people generally form their sexual
fantasies around whether you're yeah
a man in the bottom and the guy says by
the way I'm a man I
wanna be the bottom if that's cool but I
think he just doesn't want people to
know it who it really is but he's just
going away to overboard with it because
I mean he's saying guy friend yes I want
it those aren't your friends you [ __ ]
that also nobody knows you because it's
on Craigslist so just say exactly what
you want that's what I mean yeah you're
already anonymous that is what you don't
need you don't need to be cagey on
[ __ ] Craigslist yeah it might as well
be called cagey list you know what I
mean Nicholas Cage the way you laughing
stop it
we want to read this one yeah I know how
to read
uber driver wants to watch parentheses
Los Angeles I'm pretty open couples are
ideal but all considered I have a pretty
big backseat can I need a ride 48 aha
white what white male dad type but this
is the best part is the first thing he
says is I'm pretty open and the last
part is do not contact me with
unsolicited or services or offers so
he's really not that open don't ya know
I don't know yeah that's [ __ ] what I
why why do you why does it have to say
that honestly you just definitely
anytime you see something or you're like
why is it saying that it's cuz they
legal somebody doesn't want to get the
[ __ ] suit out of them ya know [ __ ]
weird
ya know it's actually not couples or I
tricked him
couples are our ideal but all considered
I have a pretty big backseat need a ride
so he's being cute about his butt right
I have a pretty big backseat he's a
[ __ ] over driver driver for real yeah
yeah so he wants to like drive around
couples that [ __ ] maybe oh maybe no no
no definitely he's being cagey why
doesn't he just say I want couples to
sit in my backseat that's pretty big and
I want to [ __ ] or like take it a Costco
you know what I agree yeah that's what
you just said that yeah okay
oh I said it I said I said the main
specific thing but you were being cagey
about it
I came through with the homerun mm-hmm
eating something hmm
what's that [ __ ] dirt run scoundrels
let's go swimming
Pomona I want to go to a spa let's do it
so doesn't just go do it you don't need
to be on Craigslist for that I'm
depressed
[ __ ] fully dude hang on hang on hang
on I'm depressed
okay feeling great dude he says let's go
swimming and then I want to go to a spa
let's do it that is sad I'm at I will
venture to say nobody's written to this
one nobody who the [ __ ] let's do it does
even have a [ __ ] period at the end
that's so depressing dude finish it you
wrote eight words you say yeah well yeah
Jesus Christ what's this one Oh smell
better for sure dude it's weird huh baby
huh how many of these people don't spell
well honestly nobody [ __ ] smell as
well yeah but this is just and that's a
problem I want meat macho guy
crossdresser here but crossdresser
crossdresser yeah it's a [ __ ] what do
you call it
Cosby's are a Croatian guy are you macho
guy want have fun HESA foreign do you
have good tool and what to used it yeah
no many tenses this guy [ __ ] is
amazing he's [ __ ] being specific - he
is he's so you got a Cruz Reiser send
pic sent pick if you serious I am
crossdresser and that's Caliente
Christmas showed a para me dress Syrio
veni who grimace I honestly now he's
just showing soy crossdresser he spelled
curse juries are both times well maybe
that's the Spanish way of saying it oh
no but how do you know because no
because it's in English without you two
letters you're right yeah it should be
just a dick cross or something yeah
our contact with the dozens of the
services or offers are you macho guy
look at horror thorn horror thorn I mean
he doesn't even know how to spell where
he is and it says it right under it to
Hawthorne okay cool well good you could
do I mean the worst [ __ ] house just
yawning help me because I'm it's very
respectful to be that comfortable in my
environment for you guys and I'm just
chillin and I yawn and that's what
happens and that's how life is and
that's what we listen to this thing and
after we have this thing to be ourselves
and [ __ ] keep it moving
[Laughter]
help needed Huntington Beach ladies I'm
looking for somebody to help me with a
little situation he's being cute I don't
like that don't like I mean the way you
said it no Kevin Spacey hi I don't like
that he's being cute I don't like that
don't need any quote favors pictures or
videos will compensate for your time hit
me up for details please what wise
favors I don't like being cute I don't
like that Hey ladies I'm looking for
somebody to help well you know this
guy's have [ __ ] like a little [ __ ]
yeah well he drugs people this guy yeah
and you know he's a [ __ ] you know
he's under 511 oh yeah he's easy he's
like the guy in of vanishing movie yep
one of my favorite movie I love them
yeah you love them Jeff Bridges is so
good in that movie well I'm obviously
talking about the original though oh
yeah that was good too which rocks ass
yeah that was really they both my French
is a French French right yeah yeah is it
by hello bear
uh yeah it's by flopper it's based on a
book called the golden egg [ __ ] smart
I knew that and it's a short story so
see there you go see is about short
story or what actually no no that's why
I said okay it's a short story I know it
and I [ __ ] nailed you there dude okay
Tourette's oh this one jack off makeout
m4m East LA anyone guys like to frot
Jacko
anyway this literally says anyone guys
like to frot jackoff and make out what
is fraud I think it means front like Oh
front Jack to each other
so [ __ ] unenthusiastic I mean well
you know I'm not gay if I was moving a
little more enthusiastic let's get
together
send stats and pics like oh my slugging
percentage in [ __ ] 2008 was was 400
what's your quarterback rating
I'm the Frank Thomas of [ __ ] what's
your credit score since stats my batting
average is 364 I've got four rubies last
game do things I guess it just means
dick size yeah so see I don't like the
cute thing how big is your [ __ ] yeah
I don't like it a [ __ ] pic of it I
also hate when baseball not to say
ribbies because say RBIs yeah or say
arse bi yeah but you know what they also
say is ribeye steaks no yeah dude it's
great Keith Hernandez says that oh I
like that I know Keith Hernandez you
listen to Chris's podcast I [ __ ] love
you did that's it is there somebody that
looks no honestly more like he [ __ ]
killed his wife more than Keith
Hernandez I mean it looks like he
[ __ ] kid
you can't possibly look more like you
killed your wife than Ethernet yeah I
mean yeah that one he killed two wives
one before he moved to America oh wow
what he did and it was both poison no it
was both like liquid like cleaning
liquid and just did so much of it while
she was sick he was like this will make
you feel better and he [ __ ] did him
both right and they're not gonna find
out that after he dies one he ended up
having to push down the stairs though
because like it wasn't good it wasn't
enough oh my god dude he [ __ ]
couldn't look more like he [ __ ]
killed his wife it's unbelievable wow
wow wow congratulations oh wow does he
have a book called I'm Keith Hernandez
is that what that is
he's like a [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean he has a book called
I'm Keith Hernandez hey yeah actually
you know what that bothers me because I
was gonna be the title of the book I
write I'm Keith Hernandez yeah
you could still do that that'll be
amazing yeah that's true actually
uh just italicize I'm I'm Keith
Hernandez you got you ever listen to
Keith earnest
does he do music
oh by staying things don't look in the
basement brown so dumb Brown you know
that's not my don't worry my wife ran
away don't look in the basement Brown
all I got down there's ribeye steaks
it's a great song mmm ours bi let's
listen to how Keith Hernandez sounds oh
wait no that's yeah okay because he had
talk he has he sounds gayer than I do
when I say Kay what
oh well don't act that [ __ ] surprised
I don't sound that [ __ ] no dude he one
time I was watching the Mets game
because I I love the Mets cuz I'm a
[ __ ] nuts man okay he there were Navy
guys there people in the Navy right Navy
guy home they cut to it they cut to the
guys and it was quiet for a second and
Keith Hernandez said ahoy sailor come on
dude dude what do I do Keith Hernandez
what what would be a good YouTube oh boy
sailors no oh really okay maybe I mean
it was that [ __ ] extreme it should be
online I'm just saying to come up with
nah it's not there it was him talking
that's him that's him on the left here
this is that guy so announcer Gary Cohen
this is us by the way on the podcast
oh this makes me hate white people by
the way yeah that was this is the most
unfunny thing I've ever know they're the
best they're the best
they're so mad by the way great work by
the guys in the truck that was superb
what are their home addresses every time
I listen to a supposed to always sounds
like the announcers are [ __ ] absolute
mortal enemies yeah boy guy batted in
runs batted in amazing 27 last season
not that good coming from it what do you
think it'll be like well you know I
agree with you but god dammit I tell you
a are gonna [ __ ] kill your wife when
I get home [ __ ] oh this actually
reminds me of a question I'd like to ask
people okay there was one comment okay
before you love there's one comment on
this video and it says you guys are
idiots lol there's our announce nope
they're talking to Keith Hernandez and
it's alejandro gonzalez said that and
there's not more baseball player name
than that okay
I mean you mentioned your dog yeah I had
a cat and my cat used to sneak into the
refrigerator and you would steal the
mushrooms
I said Louis you can't do that you can't
do that's not right he ate them
voraciously he just loving it was like
catnip to him sorry so I thought well
what the heck I better do it with him
was on the desk across from the bed for
hours yeah every story tells involves an
animal and drugs killed it he killed it
right there and why did you click that
it was there that's not why you do
things yeah
YouTube got me hmm okay there's another
one on the right says Harrison Ford is
too much I really want to click that one
don't know how about when you say
something or Google something and then
20 minutes later there's an ad for it
yeah I'm [ __ ] some [ __ ] in front
your face yeah that's [ __ ] really
weird you know what's the worst part but
when you want it yeah yeah cuz you
realize I don't know I know I know they
they know me yeah yeah yeah it's really
[ __ ] annoying it happened to me more
than once what yeah no that's happened
to me a lot yeah more than one time
that's like that's a no baby all the
[ __ ] - no but I fell for it I'm
saying like oh I've fought heard all the
[ __ ] you have to [ __ ] I bought a
[ __ ] Rock light know about a rock
light did you say rock light no I didn't
say rock like oh how the [ __ ] the rock
like come on I was a geologist that day
mm-hmm they found out you know and put a
[ __ ] quartzite thing in front of me
that had a light in it and I was like
all right Oh JA let's just have this I
must have yeah yeah yeah yeah what is a
rock what is even the rock like it looks
like a rock oh Jesus that's [ __ ]
stupid is so dumb and you didn't you
thought it was cool you got it though no
so why'd you get it it was it was there
wow I did it I did not very you I did
what you did
well you know what I wait no no no no no
no I was still a geologist well I wanted
it um I wanted it I had there was a
shirt that I liked and I bought it and
it just arrived by the way whenever that
happens do you ever buy some off an
Instagram ad it takes [ __ ] three
months to get here dude it does yeah you
know why you know why because it's fake
and coming from yeah yeah for sure yeah
it's so true but you know how you know
it's fake and coming from China what
they'll be like most amazing buying
purchase right yeah for you with glow
yeah like what are they selling frot
jackoff t-shirt yeah yeah yeah yeah
amazing buying yeah purchase superb all
right jack off t-shirt only cents you
just like what how do I what's happening
one crossdresser for sale all right
that's it you want a wrap you like how I
do that no I can do it I can't do that I
learned it in LA cañada Oh
people used to dip and they do that with
the dippings and I [ __ ] did it
whatever dude that's it that's our
podcast we're [ __ ] I hate when people
say this but we're done though
Merry Christmas I need to get the things
I dropped this house of all-time
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market enter
rewards code congrats get $5 give $5 -
times up and download the Chris D'Elia
app merch continuously being restocked
so stop saying hey it's all out of stock
you'll get it just keep checking rate
subscribe review the show podcasts
videos go up
Tuesdays Wednesdays but it's all good we
have my brother on as a guest Matt
D'Elia do you got anything you want to
say San Antonio I'm coming to you in
Austin this weekend we've Louisville
Indianapolis st. Louis st. Louis what do
you go for say no not at all no you're
done yeah I'm done guys thanks for
coming thanks for being my first guest
ever episode 100 never thought we'd get
here while we're here and I put on 101
next time because that's how it goes
good night guys
[Music]